let's try our friend eric from cancun
eric how are things in beautiful sunny
humid cancun mexico today
um hi david right now we have a storm
and as you can see my topic is that i
want to do an encore about some topics i
already said oh beautiful one would be
and would be when i said about the
[Music]
toxic fandoms about icons
i said then and i made a song stand to
point out how toxic venom is
what i'm left out to say is that there's
times that the artists are blamed for
when bad people do
bad stuff and they blame the artists
because thinking that they're being
manipulated for that
as saying that they're blaming video
games for the shootout that happened
right now and also that it would be
unfair to blame jd salinger that they
killed john lennon
uh eric do you think that the johnny
depp amber heard trial
is an example of toxic fandom
empire would be because usually they
blame men for the abuse of domestic and
in the house but i believe that john is
innocent in this time but this would be
more like when they were blaming michael
jackson for being a pedophile but then
the kid who sued him confessed that it
was his sad idea to lie about it
wow i'm not super familiar with that
case that that's amazing eric what else
is on your mind today i know you always
have a big agenda
um awesome when i mentioned about ocam's
racer then i told you that right-wingers
and confusing theories want to be like
james bond but they barely make it to
austin powers
and the point would be that aside from
wanting to be a super spy the thing is
that they would believe in those things
because one of their biggest fears is
another is admitting that they were
wrong but there would be times that i
wish to be wrong when i know something
bad is going to happen sometimes would
be when i knew that daenerys would
become her dad and would burn
king's landing awesome when
i woke with the staff cyberk and also
when sugo would betray katara
right also when he was going to die to
save the multiverse from thanos
well eric you've really said it all i
only understand about 15 of it but it's
such a pleasure to hear from you and i
hope you're doing well
um one more one last one
okay and
awesome there would be a part when i
said the politician would be based their
policies and cartoons
and if you'll remember grandpa cause
wouldn't put himself as aaron [ __ ]
from attack on titan and kill joe biden
as he colossal titan i do remember that
yeah paul gosar published this uh vid
cartoon of him like appearing to kill
kill biden and or aoc i think
there will be spoilers in the fourth and
and becomes a titan and then he wants to
use his powers to kill the all the
titans to save humanity from being eaten
by them but in the fourth season he
becomes a sociopath because he blames
the neighbor kingdom from creating the
titans and he kills 80 percent of the
population so maybe it will fit to
his kind of party of being genocidals
well eric you've said it all uh i really
appreciate your call okay
thank you and be good all right say hi
to fern cousin for me oh of course
farron absolutely i will say hi to
farren there is eric from cancun with
another powerful declaration of all
kinds